[Music]
all right hey there everybody
looks like hopefully the microphone's
working because it was like i keep
hitting my head on the [ __ ] yeah
let's just drop down a little bit
yeah well because sometimes i try to you
know but sometimes i forget that it's
there and sometimes i turn my chair like
if i'm going to the bathroom or
something i'm just like
she gets hit in the head with a
microphone boom we we
saw it coming that's not going anywhere
though
well you know i don't go anywhere okay
so uh doing that we wish we
saw a full metal jacket it was yesterday
wouldn't it yes last night yeah
yeah which uh you had seen it before
right i had also seen it before but it
had been like a really long time since i
had seen it i
had forgotten how old this movie was
yeah 87 this game yeah i thought it was
came out in the 90s tammy said love your
shirt thank you i thought i would do
some kubrick representation
this is one of two kubrick shirts i have
i also have a clockwork orange one
this is a great movie um this is the
least
kubrickian of kubrick's films it really
is
yeah there's not a lot of hidden
messages in it or anything
um but you know having been in service
i i was in service after this period
this would have been like from my dad's
era my dad was in vietnam
and uh mo this movie basically checks
out with uh marine corps for the time
and uh you know our the the basic
training experience was exactly like
what we got
we had our own version of our lead army
all right he was his name was
drill sergeant brown big old black dude
[ __ ] was awesome
and then after basic training got set to
[ __ ] korea
and guess who gets [ __ ] deployed to
our unit drill sergeant brown and he was
a [ __ ]
he ended up becoming a squad leader and
he was a [ __ ]
legend he was a legend in basic training
and he was a legend in the unit
it was good to see him again uh he
pretended like he didn't remember any of
us
he tried to wipe the slate clean it was
funny
but anyway uh watching this movie i was
like uh yeah it's good
it's a great vietnam movie um
i don't know if it's as good if it's as
great as apocalypse now
there's very different kind of movies
did you know that our lee ermey was also
a consultant on apocalypse now you
should of course yeah he was also
he was just the go-to guy yeah he was
also with another one that most people
don't know called the siege of fireblaze
gloria he was in that movie
yeah he was in some movies prior this
wasn't the first movie that he'd done
but um just brought him into fame though
yeah i mean
and you know obviously like even like
later movies like the frighteners and
stuff like that where he essentially was
playing this character except like a
dead version of it
which i thought was like really funny a
lot of the stuff you see irmi do
is kind of ad-libbed that wasn't really
in the script he had better ways to do
it because he really was a drill
sergeant
during that era during that era so he
knew what how it really was
how filthy the language really was um
there's a lot of stuff about this movie
that that is awesome if you were ever in
service
you know uh you know the culture uh
now marine infantry and army airborne
infantry they're
dissimilar culture there are some
differences
but uh no i just loved it loved it it's
good movie i
i would say probably when it comes to um
uh kind of like apocalypse now
is not as accurate all right in terms of
like history it's based on a book
that had nothing to do with vietnam yeah
like a fictional book that was updated
to the vietnam era right
but but with apocalypse now
the the spiritual meaning behind that
movie is very accurate it's very
very much pro-warrior ethos it wasn't
pro-vietnam it was just
pro growth and that's really what you
know how that that's really how
um amelia saw
combat in military service he really
wanted to go but he couldn't go
this one is different this is kubrick
kubrick's trying to tell the story of
how
very average guys are slowly turned into
killers basically yeah that was kind of
what interested him
right now
as a civilian i think probably watching
this you would probably be a little more
stunned by it
but being ex-military we have a
different take on it
so a lot of stuff that was shown we kind
of know how to handle a little bit
better like
some of the things that were being said
to the ears of a
civilian that might be very shocking but
to us that
we would consider that to be kind of
like military humor military humor
is very gallows humor and real filthy
so you have guys who are [ __ ]
basically almost like a married couple
and they're sitting there just [ __ ]
cussing each other out using racial
slurs and [ __ ]
it has nothing to do with hatred those
dudes love each other the same dudes
that are saying that are out there
trying to save him and gets killed to
try to bring him back it's just
no holes barred especially that era that
era was a
even probably tougher than even the time
that i was in
um well because you have to think too
particularly during the vietnam era not
everybody had chosen to be there
some of those forces were drafted yeah
right
and just that era was a product of
the thinking of world war three you know
same thing with the era that i was in we
were training for world war iii
which was nuclear confrontation with the
soviet union
along with mass mass armored columns
and vietnam style proxy warfare on a
global level where it might be
jungles or forests or we had to be ready
for anything
and the mentality had nothing to do with
them today
today is kind of almost like law
enforcement we'll go out there and be
peaceful no no no no
it was a it was basically kind of like
attempted genocide that was just
the mentality you know we double tapped
in the [ __ ] kill zones everything was
ambushed counter ambushed moved to
contact
[ __ ] raids
airborne operations so the mentality of
this era and
in my era was very different than what
you'd see today um
like you targeted civilians that's what
you were supposed to do
you know supposed to fight past the
enemy army and [ __ ] punish their
civilians for
letting those guys come into power or
and or you know uh like you know we we
we beat germany because we just bombed
their civilians you know same thing with
japan
like 42 cities just leveled men women
children
that was just the whole idea of warfare
because those people were all breeding
and making soldiers and working in
factories and they were all part of
there was no such thing as a civilian in
the old mindset
civilians were part of the enemy war
effort
and this movie is really kind of about
that too it brings that into
it was the first of the weird kind of
fake wars
forever wars like you have in
afghanistan where they don't really
intend to
achieve anything they just oh we're
going to come here we're going to help
you
we're going to shoot these random people
and it'll all work out and but
in the meantime we're making money and
all that becomes
all that's kind of discussed in this
movie in in different ways
i liked the movie though yeah louie was
saying that um
that he knew somebody that was a marine
and said that this was really accurate
probably the reason for that is that uh
it's actually based on a novel called
the short timers
that was written by a marine that was in
vietnam
and it's also kind of based on a
non-fiction book by a dude named michael
hare
who was a war correspondent during
vietnam and had written a non-fiction
book about it
what kubrick did is i think he read the
short timers and he loved it because
honestly
i didn't realize but this was like his
second to last finished movie
i mean the shining he made the shining
in 1980 and then he didn't make another
movie until this one
yeah and then after this one he made
eyes watch shut in 1999 and then he died
so he only made like three movies like
in the last 20 years which i didn't even
realize
um but yeah but this obviously this was
the first war movie uh that he made he
made one called paths to glory
actually i think even his first his
first movie what was that called fear
and desire i think
uh was a war movie too but he's since um
you know kind of like uh didn't want
that associated with his name anymore
because he thought it wasn't that good
um and dr strangelove is kind of
considered a war movie as well even
though that's kind of more of a dark
comedy
but so what he did was he read the novel
he had been thinking about actually
doing like a world war ii like holocaust
movie and so that's initially what he
was going to do but then
like when he started talking to michael
hare who had been a war correspondent
for esquire i think
in vietnam and he's like okay well no
let's do a vietnam movie
and then they what he did was he had
gustav hasford who was the guy that
wrote the short timers the novel and
michael hare the guy that wrote
the nonfiction vietnam thing he had them
both
write like a screenplay and then but
they didn't read what each other was
writing
you know what i mean and then he would
take both versions and kind of like edit
them into what he wanted
which i guess explains maybe
why this movie is a little bit it's
almost like
two short stories you know what i mean
sort of
they're like thematically similar
obviously but
it's kind of i mean the movie's kind of
like in two parts like the first part is
like basic training and then the second
part is vietnam yeah that's because when
when you go into service that's how you
see your service as in a bunch of
episodes basically yeah it's very
different yeah it's like episodic
yeah so that's the way you actually so
you're experiencing it as if you were
there
you see there's one episode that's
that's basic trending and then when you
get in country
and it's kind of left ambiguous at the
end they they were getting ready to go
home but
i guess they made it home
yeah you know what um yeah i guess so
they just ends up singing mickey mouse
which means [ __ ] in the service
yeah because they knew what they were
doing was kind of [ __ ]
um it's still a great movie though you
know what i mean
it was uh pretty accurate based on
everything that i know and all the other
stuff that i've read
from that period and what the conflict
was like i've studied that conflict
for all of my adult life and was in a
lot of the
famous units that were in there in that
conflict
now there was another movie that came
out i think it came out when i was in
service
i know i saw it in service and i
remember everybody talking about it
i was in service between 90 and 94. and
to me
i remembered that and haven't seen it
since then i remembered it being
super accurate it was called hamburger
hill
and i think it was about the 101st
airborne division i think it might have
been about 327. i remember it was in a
unit
either i knew or a unit that i was in
and that one was also if you like that
one you probably if you like this one
and apocalypse now you probably like
hamburger hill also
i remember liking that one but i haven't
seen it since it came out i might have
seen that in the theater or maybe like a
year after
it's about air assault operations and
what it was like for that was more of
like what my experience was like
you know not so much the the combat
parts of it but just the daily
operations and how we did things
and just the lingo and everything and
doubt how people were and what they
thought of things
some of the stuff in this movie is not
100 accurate the way it would be
like the scene where they find out that
the sniper was a feat was a was a young
girl
and then they had to think about what to
do and they kind of and
joker finally decided he was gonna
basically mercy killer and they were
kind of like a big
deal in real life if those guys that
were there just
they would do that without even thinking
about it they just go up well i think
well it was for the impact on the
audience well yeah that's what i mean
that was kind of like some dramatic
license because i think it's really
interesting because
i think a lot of people maybe perceive
the last scene
where he kills that sniper girl yeah
um you know because she's down there
saying shoot me shoot me yeah
and shoots him out of and shoots her out
of mercy but
i think a lot of people perceive oh
that's how joker like lost his humanity
because he was supposed to be like the
only one left
that had any but i was watching like
another interpretation of this and they
said no that's not exactly what it is
that was a mercy killing they're like
the other guy animal mother wanted to
like leave her there and let her
die right yeah um so so actually joker
like maintained his humanity because
he's like you know we can't leave her
like that
and then that was to put her out of her
misery right exactly
exactly so so it was actually like not
oh joker's like humanity is gone now
it's quite the opposite actually no
they clarified it that's what i was
saying some of the things i think are
misunderstood by civilians
animal mother and the other guys as soon
as they found it they said well there's
nothing we can do for
they actually mean that they couldn't
even get a tank to come help them
yeah so she was gonna die anyway you
could sit there and just let her die
that might take
15 minutes it might take a half hour but
medevac wasn't coming
all right she would she was going to die
if you were just
plugger she would have you know i mean
you're putting her out of her miseries
you would save her [ __ ] 15 minutes of
[ __ ] slowly choking today well
because she
i mean she was [ __ ] up she's [ __ ] up
and she killed three dudes
they wouldn't let her live yeah yeah
that's just not gonna happen
um by rights
if they were really pissed off they
would have cut her head off while she
was still alive
or well they said that that was actually
shot but they didn't show it
picked her up beat on her a little bit
that animal mother was supposed to just
like cut her head off and be like see no
big deal you know what i mean like that
which would have hammered at home but i
think it would have been a little too
yeah they it's kubrick thought it would
be a little too much they did shoot it
though
yeah well one of the probably more
likely things they would have done is
gone on there and just kicked the [ __ ]
out of her while she was dying for a
little while and just let her die
that was probably more because they you
know we said well that's terrible
the whole [ __ ] thing was terrible she
just killed three of your friends
yeah i mean yeah and you're frustrated
there's nothing else you can do about it
you're at you're being asked to do some
[ __ ] that's just an impossible task
uh you know the war is not gonna be won
no one really seemed to know exactly
what
was going on nope you know what i mean
it was it was a giant [ __ ]
cluster yeah that's another rolled into
one thing
yeah that's another thing that a lot of
civilian watchers
or viewers of this sometimes have a hard
time getting a grasp on you could meet
soldiers in these theaters that wouldn't
know what even what was going on they
just got there
that's not surprising that does not
surprise me at all yeah nobody's told
them anything
they're just in a pack going i don't
know what we're i don't know where we're
going
what's going on yeah they don't even
know what the hell is going on yeah and
the guy leading him probably doesn't
really know all that much what he's just
told to go to a certain location he
doesn't know why
um another thing that was common
was common is that the average person
did not ha
did not know the rules of engagement
that means that they didn't know what
the rules were for shooting somebody or
not
it was just kind of this vague nebulous
idea you
will deliver a body count if you kill
the enemy will win
you you we are expected to kill x amount
of enemies per week
and you go well who is the enemy find
the enemy you don't know what the enemy
is
some of them just started shooting
civilians yeah so
weird rumors would start well if they
run from you their their enemies shoot
them
nah that wasn't always what it was
either you know what i mean
a person could just run because they saw
helicopters and got scared it was just
another south korean
you know or should be south vietnamese
uh another one would be um
black pajamas if you're seeing those
black pajamas that's vc
man half the damn people were wearing
black pajamas that didn't have anything
to do with vc yeah the vc wore black
pajamas
that was just their work clothes so yeah
that was just their work clothes it'd be
like saying you see dude wearing jeans
he's the bad guy
yeah you know they were all wearing
jeans yeah so
a lot of them didn't know the rules of
engagement and if they followed the
rules engagement they'd never get any
kills and if they weren't getting kills
they'd get punished
because they had to kill the enemy and
they couldn't find the enemy
that was the problem yeah like i said it
was a gigantic fight and gigantic
cluster
arvin was with him south vietnamese army
they were with them and they were kind
of
had their eyes on ethnic cleansing too
because they were fighting over ethnic
groups were fighting over land
so they were kind of encouraging the us
army hey
the bad guys must be these guys kill
those guys we've been
we don't like them go kill those guys
[ __ ] like that what's going on
well and i think that's one thing that
full metal jacket does particularly the
second half of it really does capture
and grant there's hammer pointed this
out too pointing out like the absurdity
of war perhaps not as good as like dr
strangelove did
but that seemed to be something that
kubrick was always really fascinated by
not only the absurdity but also like the
inhumanity of it
yeah um because he made a lot of movies
with that type of theme to it
and this one has that too yeah but you
go
you got to go to apocalypse now to
understand that war is not absurd
what's absurd is the way governments are
asking you to fight wars
well that's kind of what i meant these
are industrial wars
yeah it's like asking mcdonald's to go
out and win the damn wards it's not
about
especially in this area era it wasn't
about finesse or generalship or finding
the enemy and
trying to solve that solve the problems
so the war isn't it's more like
we believe there's 30 000 enemies if you
kill x amount of enemies a week we'll be
out here in five years go do it
that's what they think you know what i
mean so you're asking a basically a dumb
big corporation to try to get something
done that would take
a bunch of social skill and a bunch of
that's what special forces was all about
try to find where everybody was and what
what they wanted that kind of [ __ ] how
to deal with them
this type of warfare was obsolete even
back then
yeah all right and they're still trying
to use it today
this this type of warfare doesn't really
work what works is what they would call
today terrorism that works
but not this and that's what apocalypse
now was about
willard became a warrior when he
realized you had to take all that [ __ ]
off just put [ __ ] body paint on
and take a machete and cut that dude's
head off he was the one that was
responsible for it
not everybody else yeah that type of
deal
and that and they had to kill willard
excuse me willard had to kill colonel
kurtz because colonel kurtz had figured
out that the war was a scam and you
could just do it basically like a tribal
terrorism type [ __ ] and he was getting
results that the army could never get
and
could never get so they had to get rid
of him because they didn't want the war
to end they wanted it to continue so
they could
make career points war is tribal it's
primitive
and it's genocide that'll work all this
other [ __ ] won't work
don't do it don't do it unless you're
going to do it that's the that's the
[ __ ]
that's the that's the moral of it
just like mr miyagi said you walk on one
side of the road or the other side road
you don't walk down the middle of the
road you get squashed
that's it's that same basic idea don't
wage war unless you're willing to go all
the way
and it's [ __ ] brutal yeah let's uh so
let's talk about
uh arleigh ermey for a minute because um
so as most people know he was actually
brought on as a consultant
because i guess he kind of um you know
he was he'd been in movies prior to this
and had played drill sergeant-type
characters um
but and he'd also been a consultant on
several other war films including
apocalypse now
so he was contacted by stanley kubrick
who
just initially wanted him to be a
consultant and to
essentially be the drill sergeant for
the actors that were gonna please like
you know do what a drill sergeant would
do and like
you know get him up in the line but he
wasn't initially supposed to play the
part
the dude that was supposed to play the
part was the guy that ended up playing
like the helicopter gunner that was
shooting down
all the random civilians that were right
like running around he ended up playing
that guy
um because when they brought arleigh
ermey in there
and he started doing his drill sergeant
thing
and like you know yelling and he and
most of that was like ad-libbed
finally they were just kind of like okay
well um he should just be in the movie
because he's like [ __ ] great
you know what i mean he's getting
questions here question for tom
did your di ever punch you in the gut
during basic training as hard as the
gunny punch joker
okay
you have to understand something when
you first go into basic training there's
a lot of guys in there that aren't going
to make it
those dudes basically are driven out of
there in the first few weeks
most of the guys who are left want to be
there
um they're starting to integrate and
incorporate into a unit
the drill sergeant is part of that
situation
he's by the time that by the time all
the riff-raff's out of there
your relationship with the drill
sergeant is [ __ ] very strange it's
kind of almost like s
m he's punishing you but he's making you
stronger
you kind of like you like him they have
a they have a lot of character
uh charisma uh there's uh
kind of a cult mentality starts going
i've had my drill sergeant
step on my hands like while i was down
doing push-ups
but it wasn't for me it was so the other
recruits could see it
so he could kind of be impressive
technically that wasn't legal but am i
gonna rat him out hell no i'm not gonna
rat him out we're on the same team
in the day that this is supposed to be
taking place could have could uh could a
drill sergeant punch you yeah
they could punch you and you had to just
take it like a man
um the thing is those joker wouldn't
have ratted him out
besides what are they going to do you
know i mean he was probably drafted well
no
i don't think i think at this time
marines only took um
volunteers it could have been drafted
could have been drafted
you might have been drafted and then you
can volunteer for the marines i'm not
sure exactly how they did it yeah they
didn't really bring up
uh if any of them but drafted like none
of them openly said like all of them
seem to have chosen to be there
and then you asked me how many low iq
piles were there we had some but they're
some of the first ones to go
um but uh in those first few weeks one
of them name was scott i remember him
and he scott was worse than that but he
was out in about two weeks but we
laughed about him he was [ __ ] funny
just we got a lot we got punished and
everything just like the show
for scott um but the drill sergeants
keep them around to use them as kind of
like a training tool they know those
guys aren't gonna
make it so they just use them as a tool
to use against the platoon
and then they kind of use them as uh
kind of like [ __ ] comedy props for a
while and then
then then they get rid of them um the
thing is about
pyle in the the pile character in this
this wasn't that wasn't a normal
situation that was something you can
look this up i'm not lying this was
called mcnamara's morons
robert mcnamara came up with the
brilliant idea that you could take
mentally challenged people and draft
them and it would be good for them
their survival rate in the service was
extremely low
and uh for a lot of different reasons if
they ever made it into the field
and they got went into a front line
infantry unit and they started going on
patrols
they were mostly killed within a couple
of patrols
and i think a lot of times friendly fire
they made too much noise
they were not trainable they were risk
to the to the unit
so the first time they ever had enemy
contact the guy next to him plugged him
in the back of the head usually
that save trouble later on because they
would
compromise you some of them they
couldn't whisper you know just
they just weren't and that was that was
basically like mcnamara should have been
punished for that [ __ ] that was a crime
against humanity yeah that's pretty
[ __ ] up that was like that would be
like drafting children
yeah yeah well and they kind of i mean
in this they kind of show pyle was
very much had a child's mentality he
didn't really know how to lace his boots
yeah you know he could they had a scene
where joker was like buttoning his shirt
for him and stuff and he was saying you
know i need help and all this other
stuff
and you know yeah they kind of keep him
around because he can't like he doesn't
have any self-control you know he steals
the jelly donut and then everybody gets
like punished and then everybody starts
hating him and starts beating on him
yeah i don't think that they
i don't think that um the drill sergeant
maybe he didn't know that oh you do but
no i mean
i was gonna say i i don't know if he
knew like in the context of the movie
that pushing him that far would get him
killed you know what i mean no no he
didn't know that
that's what i was gonna say those guys
usually wash out
you know yeah he probably just thought
well he's not gonna be here long he
didn't think oh he's going to shoot me
and then shoot himself
that was the only thing i mentioned it
during watching the movie i said
because uh drill sergeant started
doubling down i will make you
i will make you into a marine yeah and
he kept pushing him harder i will make
you into a marine
man when our drill sergeants did that to
one of those kind of guys it was mostly
just
they didn't actually mean that they knew
that those dudes wouldn't make it they
just wanted to keep them in there for a
couple more days
and use them as a training tool and as a
bad example of how not to be
and to use them as a cudgel against the
rest of the guys
to beat the rest of the guys into a
[ __ ] group
you're creating a little mafia it was
called a cohort platoon and i was one of
them
i was in one of the first cohort
platoons then once the cohort platoon is
done it then gets sent to a unit all at
once
so you can't run from a bad reputation
wherever you go with those same guys you
went through basic trade and know you
which it actually ends up being a good
thing because if you're good then they
know you
if you're bad you can get rid of the bad
apples you can't you know what i mean
because everybody knows each other you
don't really want a situation where
nobody knows each other
well yeah that's the thing karen rob
says jenny that overlooked top is my
fave thank you very much
louis says my friend who was a marine of
vietnam failed the eye exam multiple
times
so he memorized it he really wanted to
go to vietnam
yeah well how did that work out i mean
did he come back
i don't know some of my guys did some of
my uncles were in vietnam yeah most guys
do
did anyone in your platoon screw up and
get fragged with bars of soap in
socks as you see in this movie yeah we
had
we had a name that kept [ __ ] up like
that a camera he
uh that was cake day we got butt
punished on cake day
he stole the extra thing of cake he was
a specialist so just like
just like like piled up yeah he didn't
bring it into the into the barracks and
put it in his football he got a piece of
cake
and put a bowl over it and then got
another piece of cake and ate two pieces
and the drill sergeant saw that and
[ __ ] he woke us up at like three
o'clock in the morning
oh now you're all in trouble we were
[ __ ] dead tired
and [ __ ] had us all down there in pt
clothes
informative you might want to know why
y'all [ __ ] are out here at
three o'clock in the morning
i can't say everything you said i get
banned because they're using it
racial slurs yeah what you see is the
sexual type slurs and he goes
y'all [ __ ] are this and that and this
[ __ ] because you know what today is the
sun is not up yet that sun's gonna burn
you up
gonna burn your asses up today
is cake day like what
starch yo got two cakes
how many cakes did you get i i had two
okay stop shaking how many cakes did you
get
i got what flavors would it case went on
with chocolate and the other one had it
down rainbow sprinkles didn't it
rainbow sprinkles on the cake today
is [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and you will regret the days that you
were born and he [ __ ] grass drilled
us for about three hours man and then
all day all we heard was studio
is so good that he can have two pieces
of cake and it's just
man that [ __ ] went on and on just he
beat us up
all [ __ ] day that night [ __ ] they
threw
a [ __ ] mattress on top of sterchie
and everybody [ __ ] jumping up and
down on a mattress
so very still a very similar situation
yeah yeah jumping up and down on the
mattress with him in there
he's just crying and [ __ ] stop crying
kick ass [ __ ] did you just call
him cake from then on no no
you know it's like you know like [ __ ]
he went to korea with us he made it and
[ __ ] that [ __ ] was all under the
bridge you know a couple months later
but he was still like a civilian at that
time because you're
you haven't made that transition but now
you [ __ ]
was ruthless real rude yeah so like i
said so it wasn't very but everybody
knows each other at this point
yeah you know and you've got you you're
you're now
about a month into it and most of the
guys that aren't going to make it
have already fallen out there might only
be like four or five maybes in there
yeah yeah most of them are gone some of
them are gone
in the first few days and you never even
saw them go
you just come back in [ __ ] the bed
next to you is [ __ ]
made and it doesn't have the name and it
just says [ __ ]
i think it said ets or els or early
leave
the els sign was that [ __ ] gone
so you just come back and someone were
gone
you know happened but you're so confused
the first like week you're not even
really sure what the [ __ ] is going on
you can't take it all in yeah now this
might have been
the guy that plays pyle uh obviously he
got very famous later on uh
vincent d'onofrio that's right um he
this might have been his first movie
because he was saying that he got down
because i think when kubrick was making
this
because we watched like the extra stuff
because we have like the blu-ray
um so we watched like the documentary
about it and they said kubrick was just
basically taking open
audition tapes now there were some
actors that he approached
i think he wanted anthony michael hall
as joker
interestingly but i think and they were
like in uh
because i think at that time anthony
michael hall was still underage or he
had just turned 18.
so his dad was his manager so they went
through this big rigmarole and then
finally he was just kind of like
i don't know like kubrick takes so long
like to take a movie which this one to
make a movie which this one did as well
it took like [ __ ] two years or
something
and he's like you know i'm too young i
don't really want to get involved in
something that's gonna take that
much time out of my life so he didn't
end up doing it um i think val kilmer
got asked and he didn't do it
so when matthew modine got cast i guess
that matthew modine was
friends with vincent d'onofrio who at
that time
was working as a bar bouncer right
um and so he's like hey why don't you
come down and audition
and he and the guy you know and kubrick
loved it but he's like how do you feel
about gaining a bunch of weight because
they said
um you know vincent d'onofrio at the
time was like he's a big dude but he was
like
pretty slim you know what i mean so he
ended up having to put on
80 pounds he said he ended well he said
he put on 30
and they said that still you don't look
fat enough so so he was basically like
so he ended up having to put on like 80
pounds and then it took him like almost
a year to get it back off like after
they
because he had to stay fat the whole
time they were shooting the movie which
took like a really long time
yeah and another thing that blew my mind
too which i didn't know
because we were even thinking that we
were watching the film and because
tom's like gee i wonder where they shot
this because that looks like a real
location
this [ __ ] is all shot in england
yeah the whole entire thing all the out
because you know kubrick famously he
hated to fly which
you know i feel that um so he didn't
really want to go
far from his house like to make a movie
so he found this place in east london
that was kind of like all that they were
going to tear down and they were going
to like you know
rip up this whole [ __ ] place and he's
like oh can we like knock the buildings
down and blow it up and [ __ ] and they
were like uh yeah sure go ahead
so they just let him have this whole
thing and these fields he like shipped
in some [ __ ] palm trees and [ __ ] like
that so it would look like vietnam
and then like all the interiors i think
they should film some of it at pinewood
but
um pinewood studios but i think like a
lot of the interiors were shot in like
british army barracks and stuff like
that so a lot of it was like real [ __ ]
um but when when he said that that that
all the outdoor scenes like in
the that big [ __ ] fire fight at the
end with the sniper and everything was
shot like an east blood and that just
blew my mind
i never would have guessed that in a
million years it totally does not look
like england by any stretch of the
imagination
yeah grantham's hammer said they brought
him 40 palm trees to make it look
tropical
the wikipedia page says that he actually
that he actually ordered
this big huge plastic jungle like from
california
but then when it got there he was like i
don't like it
like he didn't like it when he saw it in
person so it's like they could use it
and throw it out so they tried to like
bring in a bunch of real palm trees yeah
he ended up
um playing a masterpiece character later
on at daredevils he played the kingpin
and that was like one of the i love
vincent i love him and everything
that was his [ __ ] tour de force there
man kingpin
he was man he was so good i bought that
character i was like yeah that's that's
him that's kingpin
but yeah he's like he's just really
really great on this and i mean
everybody is pretty great in this
oh i wanted to say too like on the
documentary
on this like the making of arleigh irmi
tells this funny [ __ ] story
about do you know what i'm story i'm
about to tell about him driving around
with
uh stanley kubrick yeah so it's stanley
kubrick
and was his wife and that was stanley
kubrick's experience
yeah so it was like his wife's suv and
so i guess like stanley
is driving around like showing arleigh
ermey like all the locations like we're
going to shoot this over here and this
over here
and uh lee army is saying that stanley
kubrick was like so focused on like
and this this is going to be this big
thing and all this other kind of stuff
that he
legit like drove the suv into a ditch
rolled it and rolled it and then climbs
out the side like he opens the door at
the top and climbs out
and like nothing happened and then he's
like yeah and then he didn't even break
characters he's like okay now come on
now we're doing this everything
he's very focused he just turned he
[ __ ] drove a car
he's like what the [ __ ] is going on yeah
and like you know stanley's acted like
absolutely nothing is a mess he just
like clambers out of this [ __ ] rolled
suv
and then just keeps on talking they were
saying that hamburger hill came out in
87.
so the same year is this yeah i saw it
when i was in service i wasn't sure when
it came out
i don't remember how i saw i guess i saw
it on vhs
but we used to talk about it all the
time i want to see it again
i yeah i wouldn't mind seeing it again
too because i saw it a long time ago
i'd seen them both and i remember
hamburger hill me saying no that's more
like
that was more accurate at least compared
to my army service
and i believe it was 327 infantry is
what that movie is about that was
that was the unit i was in it was in
first 327 recon platoon
and i think that was i think that might
have been about for
one three two seven it might have been
it might have been about 502 so i have
to go back and look
the regimens are all pretty much all the
same five would do is 187
327. if i was six was in there for a
while but got sent to korea and then it
got moved back
i was in 506 it was in korea
but uh i remembered that movie being
spot on
just with the way the equipment looked
the way guys talked
um it was just like i said it was 87
when they filmed it there might have
been a lot of the 80s in it
and i was caught the tail end of the 80s
so it could be the guys that
trained those actors to do that they
kind of
embedded in them a lot of the mannerisms
that we had from
my time because it didn't really sound
60s it sounded
late 80s so you know i mean they would
have been trained by guys in the late
80s i do remember that all those guys
basically went through a basic training
to go to
to be in the movie hamburger hill yeah
well it's it's just similar to what they
did in this movie too because like i
said that's why they brought layer me on
he's it's like essentially he's
made the actors do like a boot camp type
situation
i remember that their their [ __ ]
weapon skills the way they handled their
weapons and ships that just spot on
everything was just the way they wore
their uniforms everything
the way they did [ __ ] in the field
because a lot of stuff that we would do
in the field you know it was all
hand fabricated using [ __ ] hundred
mile an hour t 100 mile an hour tape and
[ __ ] 550 cord and
we would rig things up because there's a
lot of stuff that we needed to do they
didn't there wasn't an aftermarket
accessories for the stuff so we had to
make things
you know it'd make a lot of we were
moving [ __ ] pockets off of [ __ ]
old shirts and putting them up on the
sleeves we have extra pockets and now
you can
be used come with [ __ ] like that but we
used to have to hand
sew a lot of stuff on what they would
issue us it was badass we were just [ __ ]
back then
[Laughter]
we had to make all our own [ __ ] custom
[ __ ] damn you kids today [ __ ] kids
no no we're just trying in uniform
no i'm just cool get promoted and
[ __ ] stitch come into the [ __ ]
barracks and cut out a piece of [ __ ]
uniform material and sit there with a
hand sewing machine [ __ ] with his
foot like that and
make your ranks and your [ __ ] name
plates and your tags
you can make it by hand it would be
perfect little korean dude he's called
him stitch
if you needed any insignia he'd make it
by hand for like a couple bucks
looked like it was done by the computer
that's how [ __ ] tight it was
and we taking those things back to the
states and like man where was that made
this is a handmade in korea it was just
[ __ ] perfect
guys to try to buy it from you
yeah the script the fonts are [ __ ]
great yeah these guys are
masters mike said uh hamburger hill gets
forgotten about because platoon and full
metal jacket yeah they all kind of came
out around the same time
because i remember that it was almost
kind of like oh my god there's like all
these [ __ ]
similar war movies that's probably why
uh louis says according to wikipedia
third battalion 187th infantry 187 yeah
okay yeah
all right yeah the good unit rocket
science i totally
rewatching this movie like i said i
probably saw this movie
in i might have seen it in the theater
although i feel like i probably saw it
on video in the late 80s
maybe so like a year or two after i came
out because you know i really liked
kubrick so i would have watched it
um i had forgotten how much of the
dialogue in this movie particularly army
stuff
um has really seeped into the public
consciousness
and it's like it was funny because like
we were watching it and like so many of
the lines were familiar and plus like
they
they make a lot of jokes about it on
like uh mystery science theater too i
think they did like
um they've made a lot of references to
this movie on mst and they even did like
a couple little
even like in the host segments and stuff
they had they had one where crow was
being
essentially our learning i was saying
some of the stuff that he said
in the movie um you know and this the
whole thing about
him saying like what is your major
malfunction and all it's like so my god
my dad used to say that like all the
time
which kind of like cracked me up it was
like you know how tall he was like five
foot nine or whatever i didn't know they
piled [ __ ] that high or whatever
so it's like i had just forgotten yeah
how much of this
yeah there's a lot of stuff that ermey
says that i think a civilian
wouldn't understand like he's telling
telling everybody before
advanced rifle marksmanship class you
know about you know who is
who is lee harvey oswald who is you know
charles charles whitman you know
the victim they're going what do they
have in common they were marines they
killed they
he killed 15 people you know one day
when you're done here you'll be able to
do the same
that was humor you know they don't laugh
because you're you know
you just it's just not the mentality
you're in but i think some people would
think that might be some kind of like
like damn they they they're trying to
train dudes in the cycles or what what's
[ __ ] going on here
the military had a real [ __ ] crazy
dry sense of humor about certain things
it'd be either real super dry
real super wet you were just supposed to
know yeah
it was kind of irony you know what i
mean that was that was
but the thing about it though is like we
watched that scene and then like he
tells me he's like that's humor i'm like
yeah i know yeah i know
i'm like because i thought it was funny
because i had like a really dark sense
of humor right
um it's [ __ ] up but it's also
hilarious it was hilarious the way that
he
yeah that he delivered like he was like
was like super funny
yeah i thought it was the candidates
would have been thought it was funny too
well the funny thing was the first thing
he asked was like if anybody knew who
charles whitman was and nobody did he's
like none of you dumbasses know who
charles whitman is
like one guy finally like one day and
then then [ __ ] lee harvey
says is that dude this shot from the
book suppository yeah
[Laughter]
you know what i think what made me i
mean lee ermey was like a [ __ ]
national treasure that dude is like so
[ __ ] awesome he was great with
writers too
yeah well he's essentially playing like
the same character almost like a parody
i got a lot of dirt out here with your
name on it
yeah my turn my turn dude is another 87
years
i think my favorite seat i mean of all
the lee army that's in this which is
just never enough lee army
my favorite thing i think is when he
goes down when it's christmas and he's
singing happy birthday to jesus
yeah oh my god that makes me laugh so
hard he was looking he was looking for
[ __ ] to [ __ ] with people you don't
believe in the virgin mary
yeah he wanted the head so clean that
virgin mary would be proud to go in
there and take a dump
[Laughter]
yeah and i guarantee you that [ __ ]
drill starting to give a [ __ ] about
virgin mary
it's just kind of like but yeah he's
just like i'm so glad they let him be
this i feel bad for like the dude
that uh was originally cast in that role
and then they were like here have this
consolation prize roll instead where you
just get to shoot women and children
from a helicopter and like yell about it
um but you know but uh this movie would
not have been the same
without without lee army being the drill
sergeant in it i mean it's
well they recognize that he took that
role from the dude who played the door
guys he essentially did
um he kind of and there's an interview
like i said there's a pretty extended
interview with him like on the
um the the blu-ray extras
and he doesn't cut straight out say that
he stole the role but oh yeah
he was kind of like well he didn't use
that word but the way he talked about it
he was like being funny about it and
he's just like yeah i decided i kind of
wanted it so it's just like he sort of
insinuated himself
into well he made sure kubrick saw him
doing his thing saw him doing
it yeah and so he's the right man for
the job i mean
he was yeah the only thing the only
thing that i had to say is that
the senior journal structure now irving
was already retired by that period
he's far too old to be your [ __ ]
senior drill sergeant they're not that
old
there's most of them are still guys in
their 20s yeah
they're just very good at what they're
doing because they have to run with you
and do they can't ask you to do anything
that they can't do
yeah so usually they do they are doing
what you
what they are telling you to do like
they sometimes they just [ __ ] make
you do a [ __ ] ton of push-ups sometimes
they're doing the push-ups with you
yeah so they had and you know if they're
running you they're running you to death
so they they're in real good shape
i did laugh at him calling pyle a
disgusting fat body oh yeah
that like better oh yeah oh yeah um yeah
shame and [ __ ] right well yeah i mean
all
you know that was i don't know the word
fat body was just like as one word was
just very funny to me
all the fat boys boy they [ __ ]
focused right in on you or
just well anything that was gonna like
make you stand out
like make you then yeah they're gonna
like anything that would make us
and they would just you know you are a
fat piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] i
i'll never let you in in the army they
try to break your [ __ ] spirit right
away
because they just they don't want to
waste any time but if they see you
double your efforts and you know what i
mean you actually keep it up because
there were fat guys that [ __ ] made it
one of them was named timbler and he
ended up being an e5 he was a great dude
he was overweight
but not when not when he was done a year
into it he was [ __ ] he was strapped
and he ended up being an nco and i think
he would he made it through ranger
school
yeah he was a short he's about my size a
couple inches taller but he was [ __ ]
20 pounds heavier easily
fat and he [ __ ] was a beast
they turned him into a beast and it is
that cruelty that does it
you think that's not an effective
training method hell yes it is well
obviously it is it gets it over
they get it you're sitting on top of a
fence like that you're either going to
fall one way or the other
all right depending on how you react to
what they do so they try to push you off
that fence to see which way you fall
right away
you know if you quit you're out if you
don't quit
they'll keep you around and they'll see
you keep doubling down do you keep
doubling down
it's not talk you have to deliver so
they just keep [ __ ] with you and
[ __ ] with you and [ __ ] with you
about halfway through it they know who's
gonna make it
they still [ __ ] with you though this is
the the [ __ ] with becomes
funnier yeah and not as not as uh
not as hostile it's funny though it's
good they know exactly what they're
doing
gramtar's hammer said i used to not be
able to watch the suicide scene
after responding to an execution-style
homicide
gunshot to head blood splatter all over
the wall just like the movie
yeah probably had ptsd all the time yeah
i i i could see that like having seen
something like that in real life i don't
think i would want to like watch a movie
with it
but that's a pretty [ __ ] up scene to
watch
it's funny because like i said i saw
this movie probably like 20
30 years ago and
i had remembered isn't this weird i had
remembered pyle shooting himself
i remember that but i didn't remember
that he shot the drill sergeant first
i had totally forgotten oh yeah i don't
know why i forgot that i remembered him
committing suicide
but it's just like i don't cause i
didn't remember that much about the
movie i remember kind of like matthew
modine's born to kill thing and the
peace
sign yeah i remembered the prostitute
stuff i remembered like some of the
characters like vaguely
but i don't know why that's like just
what was funny is that because i was sad
that it's like oh earlier
is out of the movie i blocked it out i
remember i remember seeing that for the
first time when he shot the drill
sergeant
i know that it was just it was for
dramatic effect
but knowing the culture it was would
have been more likely he'd just shot
himself
yeah you'd be surprised even though
those dudes might be [ __ ]
glitching out which they usually i have
seen them glitch out and they
immediately [ __ ] usher them out of
there
[ __ ] they'll grab baseball bats and
three or four of the damn [ __ ]
drill sergeants because there's three of
them usually the senior one and then two
other ones
they'll [ __ ] run and do the first you
get to get in there and chase him out
yelling at him because they're afraid
that it'll turn and attack
yeah and they never see the guy again we
only had like two or three of those
but those are all within the first week
yeah so it like it does happen
yeah but they don't have any weapons
they don't give you any weapons until
until they're way trust to you you're
already on the team by the way yeah
because i kind of feel we'll see what
ended up happening with pyle in the in
the movie
was that you know he started out as like
kind of a dim bulb
and then they actually it seemed like he
kind of got whipped into shape like you
know he
was actually becoming like a good shot
and like he got seemed to get his [ __ ]
together
yeah but it was all kind of like i guess
it was like a ruse
it was not a ruse because i don't think
it was running
out but the thing is that was from my
experience that's also unlikely
they usually don't get much better you
know what i mean
like i got the guys that are like that
can't get better it's not within them
they're usually gone pretty quick um
some guys will get better because they
weren't trying in the very beginning
that's another thing yeah but they know
there's types
they're they're they're [ __ ] they
know exactly what kind of recruit
they're dealing with
usually yeah yeah there's you'd be
surprised
people aren't as much of especially at
that age
they're not as special as you think you
are there's a lot of people like you
they know what type you are so they know
usually
the they usually know the um
what do you call it the not the ogive
what do you call it
the trajectory they know the trajectory
of a recruiter yeah well i mean once
you've had that
much experience with that you know with
people it's like you can learn to
recognize and slot them in i'm pretty
sure they're trained to recognize types
personality types that there's probably
like seven or eight different basic
types
and then once they're done with you
there's only about three or four types
you know so because the other ones are
eliminated
but um it's still a good movie i what i
thought was on
what i did what i thought was unlikely
is that you have to do first of all you
can't get hold of your weapon it's
locked up so i don't know how he got
hold of his weapon
and ammo ammo weapons are stored far
apart
and they're locked up so him being able
to get a hold of a loaded weapon just
because he wanted it nah not even in
that era
um but if he did somehow get a hold of
his weapon and his ammo he probably just
would have shot himself not the drill
sergeant
you'd be surprised because they're in a
way the guys who are failing are [ __ ]
terrified
of the dude and that one and one of the
main things they're terrified of is
there
they're terrified of disappointing the
dude
that seems to be like the main thing
yeah yeah i mean it's not like that it's
not like they're being terrorized in the
same way
they've they don't want to get in
trouble and they don't want to
disappoint the [ __ ] child starting
that's really
like yeah that's something that they
don't [ __ ] really talk about that
much
he's not so much of a as an alien
outside force as you think within days
you're you're trying to
live up to the demands you know
you're trying to be there you're not
trying to go yeah you know
yeah gram through hammer said the very
next scene after the suicide scene was
the hooker scene
yeah it really was like kind of this
yeah and it should
you know i think everybody knows this
but like that whole scene with the
with the hooker talking to um to uh
joker and the other guy
you know with her being like you know me
so horny be lovely
you know that's where they got that
standard [ __ ] well that's where they got
like two
that's where two live crew got that song
from which fun fact
i graduated from high school in 1990 and
you know i don't know if they do this
anymore but used to be able to like vote
on like the senior song and the senior
colors and blah blah blah
and the song that won or
you vote wise was me so horny yeah they
would uh and the school was like yeah no
we're not having that yeah
but that was the one that i didn't vote
for that but it's like
they would though but yeah but i'm like
yeah that that figures
yeah knowing that people have to high
school like that doesn't surprise me one
bit the school is like uh no
they made us actually have uh
let the good times roll by the cars
which like didn't even come out that
year
that was older so i'm like that's dumb
most of us were trying to get because we
know we're all goth kids we were trying
to get love song by the cure but
i guess that didn't get enough votes or
they didn't know about that song or
whatever but yeah they were just mad
because so many people picked me so
horny although that would have been
really really funny if they'd like let
us have that
yeah all day get the [ __ ] off my
obstacle yeah that's that's
that's [ __ ] right off exactly
[ __ ] you doing up there you know you
jacking off up there come on down you
[ __ ]
oh it's [ __ ] funny the thing is
though is that that ladder that they had
him climbing
that was the easy one uh that one was
just little two by
like boards the ones we had at
actually that wasn't sand hill that was
it that was at fort campbell that was at
the air assault school
that's right so it wasn't basic it was
aerosol school
but it was like a ladder like that but
it was made out of
big round logs
and as you went up they got further and
further apart so those last
two me being five six you had to get up
on the side
stand up and if you reached up like that
you could barely get
you could barely grab it so you had to
jump and get your hands locked up around
it like that and then put your feet on
it and
then you had to do it you had to do two
like that but by the time you were up
there man you were over three stories in
the air
i mean you literally could die if you
fell now
the ground underneath there was sawdust
so you you survive it so you might break
some bones though yeah you might break
some bones on the way down
but you had to climb up one side get the
very top one and then rotate over and
then climb down
i don't know if it's that high anymore
that was like
a little three s having a hard time with
that [ __ ] yeah
that was the thing they were running
girls through that course too
and some of them didn't make it though
but
but the thing is is that that obstacle
was not like a make
or break obstacle you could fail that
obstacle and still pass the school
yeah because like i said there's only so
much like if you're short if you're
short as i am there's just no way that
anybody could jump that
yeah i think you could fail one obstacle
and that's the one that where
all the girls failed on that one if they
were short yeah because like i said
there's
i can only jump so high you know what i
mean it's like i'm a little i'm a little
person
right not a literal little person but
i'm like
a lot of them wouldn't try it they get
up there and they're going there's no
way [ __ ] yeah
back down here come on down here yeah i
really like yeah yeah
i'm not getting up there right
[Laughter]
but the ones underneath it were in in
comparison
as hard for them as it would it would be
for me to get on that one you don't talk
about yeah yeah
because they slowly as you went up they
got wider they got wider yeah
so they already went through a couple
that they had to basically jump
yeah yep little shrimpy girls
yeah oh well private pile get off my
obstacle right
yeah yeah oh there's all kinds of
[ __ ] funny [ __ ] man it's so funny
if i could if i had somebody some of
this i'm
still in contact with a lot of guys that
[ __ ] went to basic with and they'll
[ __ ]
throw out something that's it'll just
[ __ ] give you a flashback remember
exactly
man what'd you say makes you
remember because you burped no because i
remembered oh okay remember waking up at
like
four o'clock in the morning had drill
sergeant shy ree who was not our drill
sergeant it was a drill sergeant from
another platoon
he came in there and [ __ ] with us
[ __ ] with us
because our platoon was moving ahead of
his platoon
so he wanted to cost us some sleep and
how he did it is he went in there and
found
the wall locker they had the fire guards
and they've got two guys that have to
stay up at all times
and i think it's to make sure nobody's
[ __ ] sneaking out nobody's running
away or something i don't know
it could be just a [ __ ] with you because
you got to pull security that goes down
the bed so you never get a full night's
sleep
you're going to have to do some kind of
guard shift so you never get a full
night's sleep
and it's only six hours of sleep anyway
so it's broken always broken i woke up
and he had him [ __ ] crawling on all
fours one behind
one one behind the other behind him
while he went around and checked all the
while lockers to make sure that they
were locked
because he found one of them that was
unlocked was there a jelly doughnut and
here's the thing that was [ __ ] funny
is he didn't go to the [ __ ] wall
lockers in order
he hit a couple over here and then he'd
walk him over to the other side hit
someone there then come back
so he's doing the [ __ ] in a star pattern
to get all of them that way they had the
[ __ ]
bear crawl as we call it they had to
bear crawl like about
seven times the distance that they would
if they just kind of went if they just
went
because they had to go all the things
gone straight lines they had to go all
around
and the whole time he's going pulling
down on those things he's yelling at the
top of his lungs
oh this one's locked oh it's locked
maybe you did something you know
like did you lock this one no you didn't
lock it he locked it and he's [ __ ]
asleep
and you were making me wake him up and
just [ __ ] like that just yell on top of
his lungs
and then kick in the garbage cans on his
way out
calling everybody [ __ ] and [ __ ]
which i think was one thing that he
didn't tell him in this in this movie he
called them ladies a lot of
times you know you hear that a lot
that's not the way it really was
no i know but i'm just saying i think
that might have been like one of the
only slurs he didn't you yeah and all
that how much dick do you suck are you
do you suck dick
oh he did yeah he did he did get all of
that one guy like cuts maybe he didn't
call that one guy
maybe maybe he was like there's all that
kind of action like talking about
yeah because why are you eyeballing me
you trying to [ __ ] me
[ __ ] look at me just they were just
always doing [ __ ] like that you know why
are you [ __ ] eyeballing me they're
pretty ass eyes
[ __ ] like that you know just [ __ ]
funny
that's part of you you ran down your mom
was out there
staying on the mattress [ __ ] like that
[Laughter]
so yeah it's it's a good movie it's a
good moment yeah i was doing something
at one of those [ __ ] ranges and
[ __ ] i don't remember what i was
doing i had something i was hanging up a
water blivet that's what it was it was a
big old [ __ ] water bag it was [ __ ]
made out of canvas and i hear
drills starting to howl ross
ross he's yelling at me from over the
[ __ ] hill like thing you know
about 30 40 now probably 50 60 meters
away
and go to the corner yes cheryl sergeant
he goes where's the hooker i was like
what
where's hooker and i said i don't i
don't know drills hook is just a random
dude
i don't know where is [ __ ] hooker
where's
i'm [ __ ] running around like a
chicken with my [ __ ] head cut off
look at where where's my hook look at
the big old tall skinny black dude kind
of like [ __ ]
[ __ ] kid from jj from good times you
know
for hooker and i hear it's like
like that and i'll look up and probably
[ __ ] 50 feet in the air hooker's hanging
upside down around a tree
it's called it's called qualification
they make you hug a tree like a koala
bear upside down and you got to worm
your inch worm your way up it
and you gotta hang there yeah he was up
there for a long time
[ __ ] he's uh holding on and he goes
get him down get him down can you get in
what's he doing wrong get him down
like that come on down hook and he's
making me give a hand in arm signals and
[ __ ] like he's a helicopter
i don't remember trying to break down
this is [ __ ] crazy
oh he's coming and he's getting ready to
give out at any minute you know
get him safely down ross get him safely
down
maneuver him out yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
stupid
it was that [ __ ] was constant but that
was one of the ones i remember
making me do they make people do useless
[ __ ] that is just hilarious because
they're they're they're [ __ ] with you
yeah yeah they get bored
you're doing one task but they're
[ __ ] with you trying to get you to do
a totally unrelated task
for their amusement yeah and they're
trying to get you to multitask and to
[ __ ]
entertain themselves somehow well
they're having fun but it's also
to just put maximum stress yeah maximum
stress
yeah there's no sense you cannot be
inactive so they're constantly
you know [ __ ] with you constant
[ __ ] constant [ __ ]
mind fuckage finding a hooker upside
down in a tree like 50 feet off the
ground
getting ready to fall at any minute
yeah and you had to do like [ __ ]
semi-four flags
[Laughter]
because they taught us the [ __ ] you
know helicopter hand signals and pesos
that's really funny trying to [ __ ]
guide him down i was doing that
that's the last signal of [ __ ]
exactly that's pretty [ __ ] funny yeah
all right so we don't talk about the
movie yeah
all right so yeah so like i said i
didn't realize that this was actually
stanley kubrick's penultimate film
i thought he had made more than that in
the 80s and 90s but i guess i was
mistaken i know he had like a couple
that were unfinished because like he did
work on ai
and then steven spielberg ended up
finishing it later on and stuff which
probably we should do a retrospective on
one of those one of these days
i haven't seen i saw that in the theater
but i haven't seen it in a really long
time i remember like
kind of liking it and then kind of not
but i might like
feel differently about it nowadays but
yeah so uh
grantham's asked me if could dennis
raider thrive underneath [ __ ]
gunny and no dennis ray dennis raider
couldn't even be a cop
he wanted to be a cop he couldn't make
it so no they'd put him in the infantry
basic even in his prime he had been one
of the guys that been out of there in a
couple weeks
well because i kind of think his whole
thing about being um you can't have an
attitude
yeah and his whole thing too like with
him being like a cop groupie and that
kind of stuff was he'd wanted power over
other people
so i don't think he would be able to
like have he couldn't physically deliver
yeah you had to have a certain you have
to have a certain
amount of first of all you can't see
yourself as being too good for anything
you have to be very humble but you also
which he's definitely he doesn't like
that now
you have to understand rank structures
and power structures you have to be a
part
of all that you have to he he couldn't
fit into a pack mentality
that's exactly what they're doing and
that's really what part of the par
first part of this movie is about is how
to make a pack of wolves
that's what they're doing yeah and like
i said the second uh
the second one's kind of yeah some of
the some of them platoon
names are like wolf pack that was that's
very common
yeah platoon name wool pack that's what
it is
louis said wasn't btk in the air force
he might have been
yeah yeah yeah i think he might have
been that's almost a civilian job though
most air force [ __ ] [ __ ] a joke yeah i
said it
certain moses are tough you know what i
mean like they have some air rescue
stuff which is kind of like on the line
maybe
army rangers special forces not even
army ranger probably more like not even
that's that
it does require a lot of stuff you know
what i mean
um a lot of physicality even
even a lot of that fighter pilot stuff's
not that tough
i mean evidently evidently the plane's
pretty easy to fly nowadays
yeah nowadays especially like all these
kids like learning up with like video
games and everything like that they're
like well this is like a video yeah
i mean it's it is elite though i'm not
saying that
yeah fighter pilots are elite but
they're elite at what they're doing
it's a different game yeah it's true 78
said he was in the chair force
yeah most of them are support units and
medical units and service and supply
most of them are like that in the air
force it's [ __ ] cakewalk i mean they
got
carpet they got carpet in their barracks
good food and [ __ ] fancy
deploy and they [ __ ] put them up in
hotels
that's true they're in a [ __ ] hotel
they got girls
some of those units are more girls than
guys and they look good too they're not
even
army girls when i was in were [ __ ]
ugly
[Laughter]
i'm going to talk bad about all of them
but yeah don't talk bad about about
girls yeah
a lot of army girls [ __ ] um were in
there for ulterior motives they had
other ways of making money and [ __ ]
see
a lot of them were getting kicked out by
cid for [ __ ]
selling something that they shouldn't be
selling i mean they weren't all like
that but
a lot of them were yeah somebody said
well jeffrey dahmer was in the army
yeah yeah i don't know what kind of i
think he was in he was some kind of a
medic
i think uh yeah i think i think he was
if i remember correctly i might be
totally wrong about that
all right so we've been going more than
an hour wow yeah i thought this would
probably be a long because it's kubrick
and plus
it's like you know it's it's you know a
military movie and
our war movie and uh so you'd have a lot
to talk about
with that but uh so yeah so we gotta
watch a movie tonight don't know what's
gonna be
uh and then we'll do another show
tomorrow so
have a good rest of your afternoon you
guys
and thanks everybody for dropping by and
hanging out with us and we will see you
guys
again tomorrow afternoon bye